&gt;&gt; I'm here at the Autodesk Gallery in San Francisco with Sam Black. So, Sam,
well, first of all, tell us about your background.
&gt;&gt; Well, I have bachelors' degrees in electrical engineering and computer
engineering from University of Michigan, and a master's in computer science
from University of North Carolina. I've worked in various parts of the graphics
industry. I started out in workstation graphics, working on the first
commercially available X server. Then I went to work in the games industry for
a little while. Came out to California, worked for Pixar for eight years, and
then came to AutoDesk.
&gt;&gt; So you've really gone through what I consider sort of three pillars of the the
graphics industry, which is film, games, and and computer-aided design. tell me
a little bit about like, well, you know, what are the pluses and minuses of
each?
&gt;&gt; Well, they're all, a lot of, they have a lot of similarities amongst them and
so, it's really the sort of the end product that you're looking at that's
different. And everyone thinks it's the games are, or how much fun to work on
but in a way they're almost the hardest because they tend to have the most
compressed schedules. Although the film industry has tight schedules, but the
project that I was working on tended to be a little more open-ended. I was
working on the RenderMan product and some advanced rendering techniques, so I
wasn't tied directly to a film, to a release. So, I didn't feel all the
pressure that.
&gt;&gt; No.
&gt;&gt; You normally feel in those things. And then coming here to, to AutoDesk,
working on AutoCad, again very similar, si-, working in the graphics field and
it's just a lot of, you know, getting the, the right visuals out there with the
right performance.